beynat là j'ai eu à l'esprit un certain
nombre d'éléments que je crois important
d'abord à l'évidence cette audition
pourrait être utile pour être utile pour
éclairer les conditions d'organisation
de fonctionnement de la sécurité du
président de la république et le rôle
particulier qui a tenu monsieur benalla
et puis aussi pour apprécier
l'adéquation des moyens qui ont été mis
à sa disposition aux missions qu'ils
exerçaient elle pourrait également de
mon point de vue être utiles pour mieux
comprendre si au delà de la
participation de monsieur benalla à la
protection rapprochée du président de la
république qu'il revendique comme ayant
été une de ses attributions il prenait
aussi place dans la hiérarchie des
services de sécurité de la présidence de
la république
et s'il plus largement avait un rôle
d'interface des services de sécurité du
ministère de l'intérieur mais toutefois
deux principes m'ont paru rendre
difficile cette audition le premier
principe c'est la séparation des
pouvoirs
rien moi et nous passerons depuis le
début de ces auditions nos journées à
rappeler cette exigence fondamentale la
séparation des pouvoirs
en plus nous en sommes en quelque sorte
nous commission des lois les gardiens
s'agissant des pouvoirs d enquête du
sénat
donc nous ne pouvons pas prendre à la
légère ce principe et nous ne devons pas
enquêter sur des faits qui font l'objet
de poursuites bien d'information
judiciaire
il faut il faut reconnaître toutefois
pour être parfaitement exact que cet
obstacle la a déjà était surmonté dans
le passé je citerai un exemple 1999
commission d' enquête sur la sphère des
paillotes corses et la la commission d'
enquête du sénat a auditionné le préfet
bonnet plusieurs autres protagonistes
mais
elle avait toutefois pris de très
grandes précautions auditionnant les
intéressés à huis clos
écartant toute question relative à des
faits dont la justice était alors saisi
et ne rendant pas public dans son
rapport les éléments susceptibles
d'intéresser la justice
et puis il ya une autre principe c'est
une question fondamentale elle aussi
c'est la question des droits de la
défense s'exprimant sous serment devant
la commission il ne faudrait pas qu'une
personne auditionnée puissent être
amenés en quelque sorte à témoigner
contre elle même ce qui serait par
exemple totalement exclu à la barre d'un
tribunal
c'est un principe fondamental des droits
de la défense il est reconnu par le
conseil constitutionnel et par la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme et
c'est la principale raison pour laquelle
lorsque je me suis exprimé publiquement
sur l'hypothèse d'une audition de
monsieur benalla je les écarte et la
semaine dernière mais monsieur benalla à
l'occasion d'un entretien dans un
journal a donné de ses fonctions sa
propre version d'une part et puis
d'autre part il a fait savoir je cite le
terme qu'il a utilisé son envie d'être
auditionnés par notre commission
ajoutant qu'il avait je le cite encore
de quoi nous donner des explications
dès lors dans le respect des principes
que je viens de rappeler qu'ils sont
absolument essentielles et auquel de ne
devons jamais dérogé je m'entretiendrai
de nouveau avec nos apporteurs et nous
aurons une discussion interne à la
commission
et puis nous verrons à la rentrée ce
qu'il convient de faire
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire en
préliminaire à cette audition
alors ce matin nous commençons par
l'audition de deux personnalités
monsieur michel lalande est préfet de la
région ile de france et préfet du nord
et monsieur luc didier mazoyer est un
inspecteur général et directeur
départemental de la sécurité publique du
nord
pourquoi avons nous décidé avec les
rapporteurs et d'entendre monsieur le
préfet monsieur le directeur
tout simplement pour que avec l'endroit
d'expérience de l'organisation des
déplacements présidentiels il nous
explique très factuellement comment se
sont déroulées les deux déplacements
présidentiels qui ont eu lieu depuis
l'année dernière dans le département du
nord dont un déplacement sur deux jours
et qui puisse nous dire l'année l'autre
même si monsieur le préfet n'a peut-être
pas été directement en contact avec
monsieur benalla étant au sommet de la
pyramide de l'état dans son département
il a pu recueillir quelques informations
sur le rôle de monsieur benalla à
l'occasion de ses déplacements nous dire
effectivement comment monsieur benalla
s'est inscrit dans l'organisation de ses
déplacements
d'une part qui est sa fonction
officielle qui nous a été rappelé par le
directeur de cabinet du président de la
république et sans doute aussi dans sa
fonction
de fait que nous avons pu constater et
qu'il revendique lui-même de protection
rapprochée du chef de l'état voilà
l'objet de cette audition nous aurons
une audition de même nature cet après
midi avec monsieur le préfet de police
des bouches du rhône
là il ya eu à la fois des placements
privés au mois d'août 2010 est et à des
états ou plusieurs déplacements publics
c'est donc un bon terrain de
d'applications pour connaître la
pratique des choses ce qui évidemment
nous éclairera pour la suite de nos
travaux alors je me dois de vous dire
messieurs faux témoignage devant notre
commission des lois doté des prés roses
natif d'une commission denquête serait
passible de cinq ans d'emprisonnement et
de 75000 euros d'amande et je vais vous
inviter à prêter serment
tous les deux serment de dire toute la
vérité rien que la vérité messieurs levé
la main droite et dit je le jure je jure
je le jure je vous remercie
je vais donc monsieur le préfet monsieur
le directeur vous laisser la parole
brièvement à l'un et l'autre avant que
nous puissions vous poser quelques
questions monsieur le préfet merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les des sénateurs le président
de la république a fait en effet deux
déplacements dans l'est dans le
département du nord
d'une part en novembre dernier sur un
itinéraire fils l'a conduit à lille
tourcoing et roubaix sur un déplacement
de deux jours et d'autre part en janvier
dernier à onna à côté de valenciennes
pour à la faveur de l'annoncé par un
constructeur automobile d'un
investissement extrêmement important
pour le développement de l'usiné en
question le deuxième déplacement a duré
quatre heures il est évident que les
enjeux ne sont pas les mêmes en terme de
préparation ni de mobilisation je pense
que chacun peut le peut le comprendre
monsieur benalla était absent au second
il était présent au premier déplacement
c'est à dire à celui de lille tourcoing
et roubaix
quelques mots vraiment très très rapide
et très direct un déplacement
présidentiel comme tous les déplacements
présidentiels que j'ai que j'ai eu à
organiser depuis maintenant bien des
années puisque ça me renvoie françois
mitterrand ont finalement sont des
déplacements qui obéissent à une logique
qui finalement a pas tellement évolué
dans la mesure où les déplacements
présidentiels repose sur un socle qui
est celui qui est repos qui lui-même est
formé du chef de cabinet du président de
la république
gilles mas du chef de cabinet dans un
pub et du service qu'on appelle le gsp
aujourd'hui qui s'appelait autrement
avant mais ça ne change pas grand chose
et au niveau territorial sur le préfet
et le directeur de la sécurité publique
sur pour être le colonel de gendarmerie
d'ailleurs si les déplacements avaient
eu lieu bien sûr en secteur gendarmerie
venu avec monsieur l'aiguillé mazoyer
parce que ses danseurs dans son ressort
territorial que ce déplacement est
intervenue mais que ce soit la
gendarmerie vous directeur départemental
dire que la mission est la même
l'engagement est le même
et j'allais dire l'union avec le préfet
est exactement la même donc un socle qui
est qui est formé de vraiment quatre
acteurs
le chef de cabinet du président un
public la chefferie dire est aujourd'hui
le gspr qui joue un rôle absolument
déterminant capital dans la sécurité du
président il est même le sol on vous
dira tout à l'heure avec lui didier
mazoyer et puis au niveau territorial le
préfet son cabinet l'a lui-même aussi et
puis bien sûr le directeur départemental
et où le colonel de gendarmerie si on
est en secteur gendarmerie
voilà le socle sur lequel repose un
déplacement présidentiel
on pourrait rajouter du premier ministre
d'ailleurs lorsque celui ci se déplace
sur sur le territoire donc là ce socle
si je puis dire se déploie deux grands
moments finalement le premier moment
c'est dans la phase amont c'est la phase
de la préparation qui est de loin la
période la plus importante je vais
revenir dans un instant on pourrait
revenir à travers vos questions et puis
ensuite il ya le temps de la du
déplacement lui même qui paradoxalement
est sans doute dans mon métier celui qui
est le moins le moins stressant le temps
de l'amont et le temps ou si on
l'accomplît bien si on le réussit bien
si on le prépare à bien et de nature en
tout cas à aplanir et à réfréner
beaucoup des difficultés que nous
pourrions avoir en aval dont + lamont
est investi plus laval sera sera apaisée
donc sur le sur l'amont de deux grands
temps à retenir et à un premier temps
que peut être certains d'entre vous
connaissez bien par vos expériences
ministérielles ou de cabinets
ministériels aux présidentielles c'est
le temps de la détermination du thème du
déplacement est un le choix est
éminemment politique
la politique de la ville par exemple le
soutien industriel une entreprise
automobile dans le nord ce sont des
thèmes qui évidemment sont politiques
qui sont en résonance avec un territoire
comme vous pouvez l'imaginer
reste ensuite à décliner ces deux thèmes
allez décliner de manière à ce que
la manière de les mettre en scène parle
et donne ce thème une expression est une
force une puissance politique tout à
fait singulière et c'est dans cette dans
cette phase amont que nous allons
déterminer les différentes séquences qui
vont nous permettre de pouvoir organiser
ses camps c'est ce territoire ce travail
là il se fait avec le chef de cabinet du
président de la république il souffre
avec les conseillers du président de la
république
les conseillers sur le fond notamment
les conseillers sur la politique de la
ville et conseiller industriel du
président de la république voir avec
d'autres conseillers de cabinets
ministériels de manière bien sûr
soutenir le discours bien sûr du du
président et puis vient le temps ensuite
de la reconnaissance partir du moment où
l'itinérance et bien et bien bien
arrêtées ou faux tout cas stabiliser
n'ai jamais arrêté que à l'ultime fin
réalité vient le temps ensuite si je
puis dire de la reconnaissance de toutes
les séquences que nous allons y compris
bien sûr là le tracer l'itinéraire qu'on
va utiliser qu on va emprunter avec le
convoi présidentiel et le convoi de
manière plus générale avec donc le
repérage de chaque site
la détermination des personnes
ressources chacun de ces sites de
manière à donner à ceux à ce déplacement
là la force et l'importance qu'ils lui
qui lui revient bien sûr plus le
déplacement est long dans le temps plus
le la préparation est elle même langue
et plus le nombre de personnes
engagée si je puis dire dans cette
préparation y compris à la présidence de
la république est important la
préparation de balancier du déplacement
à onnaing et le 22 janvier et celle du
mois de novembre en intensité n'a rien à
voir quatre heures à onnaing et caron et
24 heures pratiquement sur le
département du nord vous rendez bien
compte que l'intensité de la préparation
n'est pas la même et le nombre de
personnels embarquée n'est pas le même
non plus pour terminer à la faveur du
déplacement dans le nord du mois de
novembre
monsieur bénard était présent il n'était
pas présent au mois de janvier il était
présent au mois de novembre
j'ai prêté serment donc je parle sous
serment je n'en avais aucun souvenir et
en retrouvant les archives de
préparation qu'on tient à votre
disposition d'ailleurs vous verrez que
le rôle de celui ci n'apparaît ni en
sécurité luc didier mazoyer reviendra
d'aucune façon et il intervient en
réalité la veille
du déplacement du président pour
préciser les conditions de son
installation notamment à roubaix et
d'été à mon avis pleinement dans son
rôle de celui d'un manque d'une
chefferie de cabinet qui s'assure que
son patron comme on dit et bien
l'installer le plan de table et
correctement fait et
son image si je puis dire compte tenu de
son emplacement sera une image positive
et puis ensuite vient le temps bien sûr
juste avant le déplacement de la
détermination du plan du plant fin du
plan de sécurité que prépare le
directoire départemental on l'a amené
vous le montrera
c'est un document assez épais qui
détermine l'ensemble des conditions de
sécurité qui sont finalisés avec le gs
père et moi même et que le directeur
départemental de la sécurité publique
met en oeuvre avec les renforts les
moyens qu'il obtient par mon
intermédiaire du ministère de
l'intérieur
car la négociation des moyens
complémentaires à ceux dont nous pouvons
avoir besoin eh bien ces moyens sont
son négocié avec le ministère de
l'intérieur les prennent et prennent la
forme de compagnies de crs et des
escadrons de gendarmerie mobile
et puis enfin vient le temps du
déplacement lui-même bien sûr qu'ils en
le qu'il a été donc une après une fin
d'après-midi une soirée et une nuit à
l'hôtel
car les chambres de la préfecture
étaient indisponibles au des raisons de
travaux et une grosse demi journée voire
un peu plus
donc encore le lendemain voilà cette
séquence qui a été qui a été quand même
très nourris sur sur le nord au mois de
novembre puis s'est passé sans incident
majeur
ayant lu toute la presse de l'époque
ayant relu tout ce qui a pu être publié
en tout cas rien qui ait flux en tout
cas attiré notre attention et je crois
que ce déplacement fait plutôt réussie
selon les dents les commentateurs de la
même façon sur le déplacement de
valenciennes où je le redis en terminant
mon intervention monsieur ben ali
n'était pas là au mois deux mois de
janvier ils étaient là au mois de
novembre et le rôle qui a été le sien
était un rôle qui n'avait absolument
rien à voir je dis bien rien à voir que
les questions de sécurité
merci monsieur préfet monsieur le
directeur le président donc je ne vais
pas reprendre ce ce que vous exposez à
monsieur le préfet simplement
effectivement ce socle il est dans la
préparation illégalement dans l'action
pendant toute la durée de la visite et
les interlocuteurs du ddsp sont le
préfet autorités première autorité en
charge des déplacements
le chef du j'espère son adjoint
éventuellement le chef de cabinet par
l'intermédiaire du directeur de cabinet
du préfet sur la préparation elle même
le ddsp doit avoir à l'esprit 3 3 grands
trois grands axes le premier c'est
l'état de la menace l'état de la menace
qui peut être d'ordre terroristes les
quasi permanent l'état de la menace en
termes de contestation sociale sur un
déplacement présidentiel il y a quasi
systématiquement et ça a été le cas même
si c'était pas de grande ampleur des
manifestations et des contestations
c'est l'occasion médiatiquement de
contester une visite de chefs d'état et
de d'avoir une caisse de résonance et c
cela nécessite donc la mise en place
d'un dispositif adapté le troisième axe
est là qu ce cortège circulation qui est
un axe important que je délègue
régulièrement amand directeur adjoint
pour la prise en compte du cortège
présidentiel moi même me tenant au côté
du préfet à la voix ou par texto
durant toute la visite est également au
contact du chef de mission g espère pour
adapter le dispositif en fonction de son
évolution
je pourrais rentrer dans le détail du
dispositif lui-même si vous souhaiter
pour la suite
merci beaucoup monsieur le directeur je
donne la parole à l'un de nos deux
rapporteurs qui la prend en premier
madame jourdain merci monsieur le
président monsieur le préfet vous venait
d'indiquer que monsieur benalla n'avait
pas de rôle à jouer dans la sécurité
lorsqu'il est venu sur ce déplacement du
président de la république vous avez
vérifié nous avez vous indiquer quelle
avait été sa participation néanmoins en
amour pouvez-vous être plus précis sur
les réunions auxquelles il a pu
participer puisque nécessairement si
elle a été notée c qui star sort d'un
certain nombre de documents alors il n'a
participé à aucune réunion
organisée autour de la sécurité c'est
clair par ailleurs il n'a jamais été ni
de près ou de loin lié à la sécurité du
président je tiens la disposition de
votre commission simplement dans les
bras les numéros de téléphone des
portables pour des tas de raisons de
sécurité mais vous verrez où situer la
monsieur ben alla dans le cortège
officiel du président de la république
ça vaudra à mon avis tous les
commentaires c'est un document du 13
novembre c'est le fac similé d'une delà
du cortège présidentiel et vous verrez
qu'il était avec à sa place et a dit
regretter conseiller technique du
président de la république très loin du
gspr de la voiture présidentielle
donc c'est un point extrêmement précis
qui démontre que en aucune façon en tout
cas pour ce déplacement dans le nord
dont j'ai assuré la supervision et la
direction
il n'a été il n'a été présent ainsi que
sur toutes les séquences et prend au dos
aux réunions techniques qui ont pu avoir
lieu sous mon autorité celle de
médiateurs de cabinet ou de lui didier
mazoyer je le laisserais répondre mais
vu à aucune réunion ni interférer de
quelques manières que ce soit dans ce
domaine là c'est le directeur oui
s'agissant de monsieur benalla je
n'avais aucun souvenir de sa présence
sur cet événement je ne le connaissais
pas mais après l'avoir vu effectivement
dans les médias aucune image ne m'est
revenu par ailleurs de sa présence je
rappelle que j'ai participé non pas ce
qu'on appelle le couvert couvrir c'est à
dire la visite à l'intérieur des locaux
sur notamment l'épisode préfecture dans
lequel il y avait une séquence politique
et de réception des élus mais j'ai
participé à toutes les autres séquences
sur cet épisode notamment sur l'arrivée
du président 20h13 en préfecture alors
même qu'on avait des manifestants qui
étaient devant la préfecture et le
lendemain sur les deux épisodes suivants
qui ont été le déplacement sur le site
de la bourgogne sur lequel nous aurons
là aussi des manifestants isolé qu'il a
fallu contenir une gestion de foule en
liesse un bain de foule pris par le
président
de quelques centaines de personnes cours
duquel je ne les ai vus à aucun moment
et enfin le dernier épisode c'était la
fin je vous remet très bien entendu les
notes de service sur le secteur dit de
plaine images à roubaix qui était la
visite d'un d'inciter d'une start up sur
lequel nous avons aussi des manifestants
qui ont été retenus par les forces de
crs ou à aucun moment il n'a interférer
vin ne s'est présenté dans le dispositif
merci monsieur directeur madame jourda
d'autres questions oui je remercie
monsieur le président une autre question
donc aussi si je saisis bien le sens de
vos propos en réalité il n'a jamais été
à proximité du président de la
république pendant ces ce séjour de
manière générale si tant est que vous
puissiez répondre à une question
générale
c'est ce rôle que vous prêtez à monsieur
benalla c'est à dire qui est presque un
rôle protocolaire dans ce que vous
m'avez expliqué c'est à dire le plan
table l'hôtel nous avait dit ça tout à
l'heure est il compatible avec le fait
qu'on le voit assez souvent à proximité
du président de la république je n'ai
d'abord redit qu'il n'était pas à vendre
ses mythes et du président de la
république il a sans doute été je n'en
ai pour ma part aucun souvenir
en compulsant
les photos de presse tout cas je n'ai
pas vu je jamais tous les documents de
presse ici vous pouvez les regarder si
vous le souhaitez je laisse à la
disposition de votre commission en tout
cas il n'apparaît leroy nulle part
peut-être une fois mais c'est même pas
sûr donc il est peut-être été dans
l'entourage du président c'est possible
et quand il l'a été c'était dans le
cadre de sans doute de sa fonction de
conseiller comme bien d'autres
conseillers qui s'approche du président
ou faire passer des messages certains
d'entre vous l'ont étés ici et le
président comme toute autorité a besoin
de temps en temps d'être d'être saisie
de telle ou telle information pour
pouvoir tout simplement répondre à ses
interlocuteurs donc sa présence comme
celle de tous les conseillers a été une
présence qui correspondaient à des
opportunités et sur lesquels je n'ai
aucun commentaire à faire là où on a
retrouvé trace de sa valeur ajoutée par
rapport à l'état territorial ça a été
effectivement dans la l'organisation
précise du de ta des deux séquences qui
ont eu lieu à la condition publique
incite à aruba est un site absolument
magnifique et où il y avait à la fois
une rencontre avec que des jeunes autour
d'une d'une exposition toi président et
en même temps il y avait un dîner
ensuite avec une trentaine de personnes
de jeunes pour la plupart
et là on se souvient qu'il est
effectivement intervenus mais à juste
titre c'était tout à fait son métier
intervenir dans le plan de table dans
dans l'organisation de ce dîner la façon
le filtrer des gens et de la même façon
qu'il s'est attaché à l'endroit où le
prénom d'un public serait amené à
s'exprimer dans cette rencontre avec ce
qui avait fait sept
cette séquence toi président il était
dans son rôle comme d'autres conseillers
l'ont été en intervenant sur le fond du
dossier sur tel ou tel tel ou tel
domaine de la politique de la ville
rien qui en tout cas ne pose à mon avis
de problème merci monsieur préfère
madame jourdain d'autres questions
question monsieur le président en suède
je veux juste ajouter une question
monsieur le préfet connaissant depuis
longtemps votre votre action au service
de l'état et la république
je voulais simplement vous demander si
vous avez eu connaissance de
d'insuffisance de dysfonctionnements
dans la sécurité du chef de l'état au
cours des voyages auxquels vous avez eu
l'occasion de participer ou que vous
avez eu l'occasion d'organiser je
risquerais bien une autre question à
laquelle vous pourriez très bien ne pas
répondre car vous êtes un préfet de la
république et donc vous êtes bien
entendu totalement solidaire du ministre
de l'intérieur et du président de la
république je pense que l'idée c'était
la suivante il est il est question il a
été question d'une réorganisation de la
sécurité du président de la république
tous telle manière qu'ils aient d'une
fusion entre le gspr et le commandement
militaire et que l'entité ainsi
constitué soit en quelque sorte autonome
par rapport au ministère de l'intérieur
est-ce que cela appelle de votre part
des commentaires et si ça n'en appelle
pas je le comprendrais d'ailleurs vous
avez compris que je ne vais pas vous
répondre
je vous remercie effectué avec les
quatre jours ou tel qu'un jour je ferai
une société de consultance comme
d'autres est effectivement je te
donnerai mes conseils pas su j'aurais
des choses à dire mais ça je laisse ça
aux experts pour ce qui est de la
première fois la question par contre là
on va surtout pas se dérober
parce que on a peu de recul et l'as et
les cheveux blancs témoigne mais je n'ai
jamais vu qu'on ne va pas d'insuffisance
dans la sécurité du président de la
république
j'ai plutôt jouer dehors des présidents
de la république réclamer de l'air pour
respirer envie d'aller au contact
beaucoup sourit ça doit vous évoquez
beaucoup de souvenirs pour certains mais
l envie de respirer l'envi de se
déplacer
ce qui est tout à fait normal enfin je
n'en citerai aucun mais je pense que les
quatre que j'ai servi plus
particulièrement aucun d'eux en tout cas
ne fait exception à cette envie de
respirer devoir d'aller voir les élus
d'aller voir les habitants de rentrer
dans des maisons on pense tout de suite
à l'un d'entre eux est d'aller passer un
moment
avec eux pour peut-être toucher la
réalité la plus la plus concret donc le
j'ai plutôt entendu des présidents de la
république parfois des membres de son
cabinet ne dira mais éloignée des forces
de sécurité ni ou vu ni osu c'est une
expression dont vous avez sans doute
souvent entendu parler
éloignons les forces de sécurité pour
données à caractère soutenable
respirable à ceux à ce déplacement
le gspr qui assurément la protection
rapprochée du président mais cette
protection rapprochée n'épuise pas la
question de la sécurité d'un déplacement
présidentiel
car n'oubliez jamais que dans un
déplacement présidentiel vous avez deux
autres composantes
vous avez d'abord les accompagnants du
président de la république
souvent ce sont des ministres parfois
certains peuvent être eux mêmes exposées
ni la défense ni de l'intérieur sont des
personnalités qui même peuvent être
exposés à une insécurité réelle
deuxièmement n'oubliez pas le public
alors quand on est prêt fait que de
présenter vie et accueillis dans une
salle
il est accueilli par une par une foule
le long d'une route et des capitales
pour nous de sécuriser cette foule qui
est qui étiez présent c'est un c'est un
sujet majeur donc le président c'est
bien sûr un sujet le j'espère est là
pour effectivement y veiller nous avons
toute une stratégie d'organisation de
nos forces en profondeur comme on dit
pour prévenir anticipé repérer les
anomalies dans les comportements de tel
ou tel et nous avons ensuite une
sécurité de proximité ssl à la plus
difficile en réalité à tenir
celle qui doit être présente mais peu
visible celle qui doit être certes très
peu visible mais extrêmement efficace
pour pouvoir
comment dire empêcher
ravaillac si je fais dire ou empêcher
tel ou tel tel ou tel individu qui
voudra pour une image éphémère sur une
chaîne de télévision
à tout prix existait et ça c'est notre
c'est notre difficulté c'est précisément
sur ce point là que réside la difficulté
n'a plus la plus importante dans un
déplacement présidentiel
alors peut-être vous m'avez pas poser
une question mais je vais me la poser
c'est est ce que finalement les
présidents de la république sont plus
défendus en france que dans les pays
étrangers il se trouve que j'ai fait
soixante dixième anniversaire du
débarquement en normandie et j'avais 22
chefs d'état
je pense que il ya des exigences plus
élevées chez certaines puissances
étrangères
nettement plus élevé à tous égards c'est
ce que je veux vous dire je préfère vous
hais ce mot mais très bien la tension y
compris intérieur que doit ressentir un
préfet qui organise un déplacement du
président de la république parce que
certes le président de la république
personnellement son entourage qui ne
sous-estiment la met sa popularité ont
très envie d'aller au contact ce qui
peut faire courir des risques du point
de vue de la sécurité
mais quand ces risques surviennent même
s'il s'agit pas de violences qui sont
commises à l'encontre du président de la
république mais tout simplement de
manifestants qui arrive à proximité du
président il est arrivé dans le passé
que les préfets en fasse les frais on a
vu des préfets et relevés de leurs
fonctions deux jours après un
déplacement présidentiel alors même
qu'ils avaient alerté la présidence de
la république sur les précautions à
prendre et que celle ci les avait
refusées est ce que vous diriez que à
l'occasion de ses déplacements vous avez
eu les coudées franches par rapport au
cabinet du président de la république
pour vous-même cherchant un bon
équilibre entre la sécurité et la
respiration c'est le mot que je crois
que vous avez utilisé est-ce que vous
avez eu les coudées franches pour
assurer ce déplacement est réalisée cet
équilibre oui je dis oui je dis sans
aucune réserve parce que dans ces deux
déplacements surtout dans le premier le
deuxième était quand même déplacement
extrêmement facile de dire qu'il y avait
pas de il avait aucun problème de
quelque nature que ce soit la question
du brouillard qui en fait la vraie
question c'est est-ce que l'avion allait
pouvoir altérer ou est-ce que c'était
par un autre moyen de locomotion que le
poésie en est-il venir donc je ne
m'arrêterai pas sur le
le 22 janvier sur le mois de novembre où
il y avait des enjeux autrement plus
conséquents que que là on a eu
absolument aucun problème d'aucune sorte
pour obtenir les moyens que nous que
nous avons que nous avons obtenus dans
un déplacement présidentiel mais
l'oublier mazoyer le dira mieux que moi
nous commençons par mobiliser les moyens
territoriaux car n'oubliez jamais que
ceux qui connaissent le terrain ce sont
les territoriaux les unités de forces
mobiles sauf quand elles sont du secteur
ce qui est assez rare ce sont des gens
qui viennent mais qui ne connaissent pas
le terrain donc il ne faut surtout pas
leur faire jouer un rôle de proximité
sinon vous vous engagez très très mal le
déplacement du président de la
république donc jacques la question des
pâtons du nombre de moyens d'individus
vous engager mais la qualité des
individus vous engager
c'est ça qui est essentiel et vous devez
faire monter en première ligne des
agents de proximité sa prise des
commissariats de la direction
départementale de la sécurité publique
qui dans le nord est quand même une très
très grosse machine de plusieurs
milliers de personnels et puis par
ailleurs vous faites venir effectivement
des moyens complémentaires nous en avons
eu deux premiers jours et 3
deux unités de force mobile 3 le second
jour qui sont venus pour beaucoup
sécuriser les arrières comme j'avais dit
tout à l'heure sécuriser les carrefours
stratégie et faire du maintien de
l'ordre là on a jugé qu'il fallait faire
du maintien d'ordre
compte tenu des rassemblements qui
n'était pas nécessairement amicaux qui
se profilait à l'horizon lointain du
président de la république beaucoup oui
on a eu tous les moyens que nous
voulions des moniales technique des
moyens humains et les moyens automobile
et franchement je n'ai d'ailleurs jamais
fait de déplacement coïncide en ciel
avec quelques présidents que ce soit et
sous quelques gouvernements que ce soit
où je n'ai pas eu les moyens de conduire
ce déplacement comme il le fallait
merci monsieur et madame jourda vous
dire poser une question oui une question
tout à fait basique monsieur le préfet
monsieur le directeur
lorsque en phase amont vous avez des
réunions avec la chefferie de cabinet de
l'élysée où le j'espère qu'elle est là
la fonction ou le grade de vos
interlocuteurs tant à l'achat fricot
j'espère l'interlocuteur pour les
préparations l'heure encore une fois
couvert ça concerne essentiellement le
cabinet de monsieur le préfet pour ce
qui concerne le déroulé le protocole et
tout ce qui se peut se passer à
l'intérieur de certains sites notamment
les discours pour le tout ce qui est
extérieur déplacement pilotage arrivée
déplacement de l'autorité du président
de la république sur la voie publique
c'est le chef du sper intuiti personae
colonel lavernée chef du j'espère et en
l'occurrence pour ce déplacement le sol
donc apparemment que benalla étaient
présents son chef de mission précurseur
l'adjudant-chef hausse et l'eau c'est
avec ces deux sous-officiers et
officiers de gendarmerie officier de
gendarmerie que j'ai eu contact
et pas avec personne d'autre alors après
il y avait bien entendu un environnement
déplacement de président de la
république c'est plusieurs personnes en
civil que ce soit des chargés de
communication voire même des personnes
du j'espère qu'on identifie alors à leur
badge que l'on rencontre ici ou là sur
le pilotage sur les précurseurs sur la
tenue de certaines issues que moi même
il m'arrive de pas
ne pas détecter mais mes interlocuteurs
que les très clairement ce n'est le chef
de mission sur le déplacement d'eau
donne le 22 janvier le colonel lavergne
n'était pas présent c'est son adjoint le
commissaire divisionnaire theroux dont
avec lequel j'ai traité est un des chefs
de mission dont j'ai oublié le nom c'est
très réduits c'est encore une fois le le
socle auquel le préfet fait référence il
se déplace il est dans la préparation
et puis on arrive près de l'événement
plus les souder et dans l'événement
lui-même ils ne se quittent plus merci
monsieur le directeur madame lherbier
monsieur le préfet de région monsieur le
directeur départemental et la police
d'abord je suis ravi de d'être présente
à votre audition en tant que nordiste et
pour témoigner aussi à mes collègues la
minutie qui est employé dans la
préparation justement de visite
j'ai eu à travailler avec vous monsieur
le préfet vous le savez en matière de
sécurité je sais à quel point la
sécurité est votre priorité parce qu'on
est quand même à la frontière belge
dans le nord on a eu quand même des
menaces terroristes très très élevé et
donc votre vigilance est plus que
nécessaire
une chose j'ai participé justement à la
visite du président notamment aussi sur
le site de la bourgogne la zup de
tourcoing et je n'ai aucun souvenir de
la présence de monsieur ben alla parce
qu'on ne fait pas attention à tout ça
mais je me suis je me souviens très bien
en étant sur le site
vu le nombre de gens qui s'agglutinaient
autour de nous je me suis posé la
question de savoir monsieur le préfet
at-il connaissance de tous les points
vidéo
quand on a été adjoint à la sécurité on
pense tout de suite à la vidéo
monsieur le préfet t-il connaissance de
tous les points vidéo qui nous entourent
point vidéo pour les zones publiques
poids vidéo d'enregistrement pour les
zones privées je me suis posé la
question en me disant très certainement
que oui en amont dans la préparation
ça doit faire partie de la préparation
de la visite et un deuxième point
toujours ce même jour
c'est très curieux parce que je croyais
que ça m'était
j'avais oublié ces points mais toujours
ce même jour je me suis dit monsieur le
préfet et monsieur le directeur
départemental de la police c'est vrai
que vous veniez d'arrivée monsieur noah
se voyait pas je me suis dit ont-ils
aussi connaissance de toutes les
personnes qui possèdent une arme sur les
lieux parce que on sortait de problèmes
de terrorisme en sortait deux et on se
sentait pas en grande sécurité
moi même je me sentais pas en sécurité
tout le monde pousse et le président
étaient agglutinées sur des sur des
grilles et est donc élevé les publics de
la zup qui était de l'autre côté des
grilles je me suis dis n'importe qui de
n'importe où peut il est en danger je le
sentais en danger je me sentais tous en
danger jour là donc je voudrais savoir
si vous avez connaissance de tous les
gens posséder une arme ce jour là est
peut-être si madame lherbier avaient
raison de se sentir en danger
vous avez la parole ouvrez pour
alternativement j'espère que vous n'êtes
pas senti en danger d'abord parce qu'on
était là pour vous protéger et que ça
s'est très bien passé
oui la première question
incontestablement on a bien sûr
les guides yema soyez vais revenir mon a
bien sûr la connaissance de toutes les
caméras publiques et privées dans la
salle de captation d'image de la mairie
on avait un policier un ensemble de
policiers qui étaient là en temps réel
et puis il ya peut-être des gens vous
n'avez pas vu parce qu'il était haut sur
les toits mais nous avions des
nous avions des hommes bien bien grimés
d'ailleurs parfois et qui était sur
toutes les chaînes tous les toits avec
des jumelles prêts à intervenir de la
même façon que nous avions dans le
centre social est au milieu de la foule
figurez vous nous avions des personnels
bien sûr spécialisé effectivement
policiers prêts à intervenir
bien sûr bien sûr mais ça c'est le
propre de tous les dépassements depuis
aussi longtemps que la république existe
me semble-t-il
madame lherbier si je peut affiner ma
question sur le président concernant
justement ces vidéos comme on a su par
la suite dans la ferme et nahla qu' il a
pu se procurer les vidéos sur le site de
tourcoing
si qui que ce soit avait pu se procurer
les vidéos vous l'auriez su ou pas ou
est-ce que c'était faisable et si si
c'était des est-ce que c'était des des
copies et enregistrer ou autre alors ça
c'est un peu ce directeur c'est préfet
et le directeur répond pour les vidéos
on ne peut pas anticiper le fait de
capter une vidéo de manière illégale
mais on arrive à remonter rapidement sur
la traçabilité parce que tout est tracé
informatiquement
donc quand on regarde un film vidéo sur
les armes par ailleurs monsieur le
préfet donne toute l'instruction dans
ces cas là pour que le service du
renseignement territoire et la dgs y met
dans un domaine un peu plus
confidentielle que assure un filtrage ce
qu'on appelle un criblage des personnes
qui pourraient avoir contact avec
l'autorité présidentielle voir boire
être sur des sites donnant directement
sur les lieux et dans ces cas là il ya
le criblage renseignements plus le
passage aux fichiers agrippa qui permet
de savoir si une personne et des
titulaires d'une arme
mais monsieur le directeur
est ce que ça veut dire que si monsieur
ben alla avait porté son arme puisqu'il
était titulaire d'un permis de port
d'armes à l'occasion de ce déplacement
cela aurait dû vous êtes signalé non que
le chef du moins qu'une personne qui
bénéficie d'une autorisation de port
d'armes soit et et ce port d'armé soit
dans la visite présidentielle non on n'a
pas vu le signal et enfin est un chef de
cabinet adjoint peut avoir un perdant
mais je ne suis pas censé le savoir je
vous remercie
y at il d'autres questions mes chers
collègues pas d'autres questions à damas
à 6 merci monsieur le président je le
précise le préfet monsieur chat
collègues voulaient d'abord vous
remercier pour les éléments très précis
que vous nous avez fourni qui montre une
certaine rigueur et un certain
professionnalisme de votre part je pense
que c'est à saluer j'ai une question
précise vous nous avez fait part au
moment des déplacements du président de
la république dans votre région de
mouvements sociaux et de rassemblement
je voulais savoir si vous aviez des
rencontres avec soin les organisations
syndicales soient les associations qui
sont maîtresses de c2c de ces
rassemblements et ma deuxième question
c'est de savoir est ce que vous savez si
elles ont des liens avec la chefferie en
amont de ces de ces initiatives pour
ceux sur ce point effectivement je crois
qu'il faut il faut indiquer qu'il n'ya
pas de déplacements présidentiels qui ne
donne pas lieu
des cahiers de doléances si je peux dire
anormal et
la chefferie de cabinet le préfet
les maires et parlementaires reçoivent
abondance de demandes pour obtenir une
une audience vous savez bien je pense
que vous avez tous vécu dans vos propres
territoires et effectivement il
appartient
chef de cabinet en lien avec le préfet
d'organiser bien sûr la rencontre avec
celles et ceux qui le souhaitent de
manière à calmer si je puis dire les les
incompréhensions et les mécontentements
continuant là ça c'est vraiment le sait
le rôle de l'amour je le disais tout à
l'heure à détecter l'ensemble des
situations qui peuvent paraître
difficiles pour pouvoir les traiter de
façon la plus optimale
le jour de la visite est ainsi
s'épargner effectivement des conflits
positif entre des groupes qui n'ont pas
nécessairement envie d'en connaître la
ou comme toujours il ya une difficulté
c'est lorsque les personnes ne manifeste
pas à l'envi d'être reçus alors ces
savants sessad ans qui sait
ce à quoi nous avons été confrontés mais
comme dans la plupart des déplacements
précédents s'il n'y avait pas de ce
point de vue de novation particulière et
nous avons été confrontés en novembre
dernier comme dans beaucoup d'autres
déplacements j'ai que j'ai assuré tout
le long de ma carrière
nous avons été confrontés à plusieurs
groupuscules qui ont tenté à plusieurs
reprises de s'exprimer au contact du
président de la république est bien sûr
notre métier ça a été tout de même de
faire en sorte que cette expression soit
la plus lointaine possible et nous y
avons plutôt réussi sans violence
particulière avec beaucoup de conviction
du directeur départemental
[Musique]
merci monsieur le préfet merci monsieur
le directeur de votre expertise à l'un
et à l'autre et deux de vos témoignages
et donc cette audition est maintenant
achevée et nous allons pouvoir passer
dans un instant à l'audition suivante
ça nous sera très utile
je vous en remercie merci beaucoup